bonsoir a tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver à la une de ça vous regarde ce
soir roselyne bachelot ministre d'une
culture sinistrés la mission qu'elle
vient d'accepter s'apparente aux travaux
d'hercule réussir le déconfinement des
musées des festival des cinémas des
théâtres à l'heure où la deuxième vague
de coronavirus menace faire renaître un
secteur qui a perdu 22 milliards d'euros
bref faire plier bercy bachelot commando
c'est notre grand débat ce soir on
parlera aussi des ravages du
déconfinement sur la santé mentale voilà
des semaines que les psychiatres sonne
l'alertent troubles anxieux des
pressions des compensations en cascade
une nouvelle vague de malades déferlent
dans les urgences psychiatriques les
plats des lieux les réponses possibles
avec nos invités tout à l'heure enfin
dans ma journée à l'assemblée thomas des
prêts nous racontera comment un
amendement voté hier soir va avoir de
grandes conséquences sur notre
consommation de tabac
voilà donc pour le programme ces partis
hashtag sévère n'oubliez pas au liban
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi
elle fait pays lee à certaines formules
que pote politiques peuvent se permettre
moi ministre de la culture
j'aime bien ça moi ministre de la
culture
non je suis pas mégalomane elle est
heureuse roselyne bachelot et ça
s'entend dès ce matin sur france inter
malgré l'ampleur de sa tâche peut-elle
relevé un monde de la culture à genoux
on en parle ce soir avec vous frédéric
dumas bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes
député liberté et territoires des
hauts-de-seine et productrice de cinéma
de profession bonsoir christophe barbier
joueurs ravis de vous accueillir vous
êtes bien sûr éditorialiste à l'express
et à bfm tv et puis comédien c'est aussi
pour cela vous êtes pas ce soir vous
étiez jusqu'au 17 mars sur les planches
du théâtre de poche montparnasse avec
deux spectacles
et puis depuis évidemment plus rien mais
vous allez revenir avec un ancien succès
détenu en deux mots ont fait deux choses
ont fait au théâtre montparnasse la
reprise du dialogue entre léon blum et
georges mandel l'un de nous deux la
pièce de jean noël jeanneney et puis au
théâtre de poche on va faire aussi début
septembre le grand théâtre de l'épidémie
les épidémies dans l'histoire du théâtre
c'est très important de et deep à
aujourd'hui en passant par roméo et
juliette
roméo juliette ya la peste pendant
rumilly juliette on oublie tous les mecs
vous allez de l'avant
comment vous préparez tout cela avant de
remonter sur les planches bienvenue sur
ce plateau françois missonnier on ce
merci d'être là vous êtes le fondateur
et directeur du festival de musique
europavox et à clermont ferrand qui
aurait dû avoir lieu il y a deux
semaines si je dis pas de bêtises ou du
monde et qui a été annulé et vous avez
aussi fondé rock en seine vous nous dire
évidemment comment vous traverser cette
période très difficile je vous donne la
parole dans un instant mais si j'ai bien
compris bachelot est attendue comme le
messie
stéphane blakowski et tout de suite
bonsoir messieurs
bon ça rigole bien alors ce soir si
c'est bien compris bah si j'ai bien
compris il faut pas rigoler parce que il
ya une terrible malédiction qui pèse sur
le ministère de la culture je pas si
vous vous souvenez de la malédiction des
pharaons
cc la légende qui dit que les premiers
explorateurs qui ont pénétré dans la
pyramide on profane est le sarcophage de
toutankhamon et que du coup dans les 18
mois qui ont suivi ils sont tous morts
eh ben c'est pareil mix'art la culture
vous y entrez plein plein d'orgueil
plein de projets d'un d'illusions
peut-être enfin heureux en tout cas et
18 mois plus tard malédiction vous
sortez reims et l'esquivé amer battue
d'ailleurs je n'invente rien cette
malédiction elles existent puisque le
ministre franck riester en parle de
lui-même sans doute n'ai-je pas tout
réussi en premier lieu de conjurer la
malédiction de voir le titulaire de ce
ministère changer tous les 18 mois mais
je crois que nous pouvons être fiers du
travail accompli ensemble
voilà vous y croyez vous à la
malédiction de la rue de valois si j'y
crois bien évidemment regarde ça n'a pas
encore été démontrée scientifiquement
non évidemment mais on a quand même pas
mal de preuves empiriques
on constate on voit bien regarder le
quinquennat hollande moi je sais pas il
y avait aurélie filippetti 18 mois fleur
pellerin 18 mois audrey azoulay 18 mois
mon pareil françoise nyssen voilà quand
on est arrivés formidable une grande
éditrice car on capte sud superbe
réussite
regardez ce que disait le figaro quand
elle est arrivée tout le monde de la
culture la police un dea enfin on a
trouvé notre ministre lui des loges
jean pierre dumont thèmes et plus dé la
joie effectivement est en revanche pas
10 ou imputent à la malédiction
ça c'était la pluie d'éloges et
malédictions 18 mois plus tard qu'est ce
qui se passe
le même journal le figaro fait le bilan
et dit quoi un an et demi de rater au
ministère de la culture et ça ne rigole
pas cette malédiction donc franck
restera lui aussi succomber l'amérique
sur les will put rien faire
il n'a pas démérité pourtant ce qu'on
disait nice n avait pas du tout
politique
c'est bien beau la société civile
riester c'est un vrai politique il s'est
pas mal débrouillé sur les arbitrages
souvenez vous un moment darmanin qu'hier
lui redoutable il voulait supprimer la
redevance
bon ben voilà trente cristers il a
résisté finalement été maintenue
canal+ ne voulait plus financer le
cinéma français ont quitté la table des
négociations
là encore il espère est intervenu il a
remis tout le monde autour de la table
et puis même dans l'assurance chômage un
moment le régime des intermittents
devait être examiné par les partenaires
sociaux a libéré s'inquiétait libé
s'inquiète souvent pour les
intermittents mais il s'inquiétait
encore une fois est bien là encore
brillé ce terrain résister vous voyez et
pourtant et pourtant elle a quand même
frappé la malédiction finalement pour ça
qu'il n'y croyez pas je n'arrive même
pas à comprendre le point de vue parce
que deviner quand l'épidémie s'est
abattue sur la france quel est le
premier ministre qui au gouvernement a
d'abord franck riester quelques jours au
lit 40 de fièvre
il a vraiment été secouée vraiment par
la maladie puis heures quand il sait lui
il allie dans les sorties tant mieux un
mot revanche la culture elle l'a après
avec l'épidémie il est clairement à
l'agonie quoi ya du spectacle on sait
pas quand est ce que ça ça va reprendre
puis je vous dis rien qui ne trompe pas
que la malédiction fait faut savoir le
regarder c'est quand le vieux phare en
langue sort de son sarcophage
oui hélas c'est jamais bon signe et qui
commence à dire des fautes ou changer de
la culture en porte pour commencer le
ministre ils étaient les artistes vous
les connaissez cessé d enfants et ils
veulent des bonbons pudique et non plus
il suffit de bien ingrat regardez ils
ont fait une tribune pour dire monsieur
le président on veut changer de ministre
on ne le voit pas ce il voulait voir
leurs ministres ils n'ont pas vu voilà
c'est ce sont les artistes qui ont eu la
peau de franck restèrent bon je pense
que les artistes qui se plaignait un peu
comme d'habitude dans celui qui a
vraiment fait beaucoup de tort à franck
riester cc président de la république
alors ah oui sa macro anglais fait
beaucoup de tort parce que il va
complètement saper son autorité dans les
artistes vous ai pas vraiment le
respecter leurs ministres gardez le j'ai
une petite liste de ce qu'il a écartée
du dossier de notre dame ont cédé dans
son registre
pour ce qui est du président le
président de l'opéra de paris on a
attendu dès longtemps ses matons qui l'a
nommé le cnc m'a comparé il intervenu le
palais de tous encore natron le couleur
bleue le dernier coup de pied de l'âne
c'est le sait plus le puy du fou de
villiers qui a droit à un passe-droit
franck riester qu'est ce que voulez
qu'il dise aux artistes donc je vous
montre une séquence allez on fait un
discours et on voit l'attitude de
riester à côté donc je parle par dessus
le président a très important mais
regardez bien comment se comporteront
voie qui n'est pas du genre à tenir tête
à mâcon regarder il opine du bonnet tout
le temps je suis allée président les
puits pour faire le bon élève
immédiatement il s'empare de son fier
aux dictats jeu peut-être la note est
salée maintenant il ya un moment on voit
bien qu'il a l'attitude du bonheur
draka state au président sur les
dossiers qui compte alors que peut-être
qu'avec roselyne bachelot on a quelques
uns qui reviennent très fort caractère
et qui soit peut-être tenir tête au
président va se poser la question
peut-être christophe barbier ces macro
qui a tué risser où c'est la malédiction
des pharaons
oui c'est un peu macron pas seulement
par cette initiative à la fin où il a
pris la main mais aussi parce qu'il ya
pas de grand ministre de la culture sans
grande vision culturelle de la part du
président on est quand même dans le pays
de louis xiv
françois mitterrand il avait une vision
a donné les grands travaux jacques
chirac n'étaient plus flottants mais il
y avait au moins les arts premiers
ça donnait le musée du quai branly
françois hollande et nicolas sarkozy n'y
a pas de vision et donc il n'y a pas de
grands souvenirs de grandes mises et la
culture mame gérer la sauce et lectures
attention emmanuel macron y avait le
pass culture mais surtout il y avait
comme candidat un goût affirmé pour la
culture la littérature le théâtre hilal
au spectacle par les philosophies on se
disait tiens enfin on va retrouver
derrière ce discours culturel cet
appétit pour la culture une vision et
une politique culturelle et puis ça fait
flop
sans doute at il eu d'autres choses à
faire avec des dossiers beaucoup plus
grave mais on attend encore pour
l'instant la grande vision de la grande
politique culturelle de manuel macro 1
sec et roselyne bachelot peut lui
apporter cette grande vision pourquoi
l'at il choisit à ce moment-là valence
qui l'a choisi pour deux raisons d'abord
pour eux réconforté les artistes et
réparer la culture après l'épidémie est
là les outils techniques et là la
maîtrise dont seulement des dossiers
mais aussi de toute la machine de l'état
parce qu'elle a été souvent ministre
puis la deuxième raison les politiques
elle lui apporte cette droite chirac au
séguiniste puis fillonniste sur laquelle
il n'avait pas encore mis la main et là
sur ce territoire de l'électorat ou déjà
avec philippe de villiers il grignotait
peut être des bons sentiments
il va avoir avec roselyne bachelot une
rabatteuse de voix tout pour éviter
qu'un candidat de droite dangereux
puissent surgir en 2020 les artistes se
plaignent du manque de visibilité de
riester la yaris traîne plus les plus
colorés lamelles et enfin quelqu'un qui
a à la fois du poids politique qui
connaît l'état et qui est assez
charismatique populaire on le voit
encore dans les enquêtes
c'est bienvenu ce soir je vais répondre
à cette question mais je vais quand même
aller d'abord dans le sens de christophe
barbier je pense totalement ce qu'il a
dit moi j'étais député en marche un j'ai
quitté après un an et demi juste avant
les jaunes juste entre hulot et écolo
pourquoi parce qu'effectivement il n'y
avait aucune vision je les dis à ce
moment là j'ai dit un vide abyssal en
matière de politique culturelle
après moi aussi j'avais fait partie de
ceux qui avaient cru à françoise nyssen
avec j'allais dire le symbole éducation
éducation culturelle et leur délivrait
c'était pour la bonne personne
et franchement on est arrivés en plus
avec des problèmes d'exemplarité qui
était quand même assez important avec la
réglementation du patrimoine qui était
absolument pas respecté ni un conflit
avec le livre et c'est cela aujourd'hui
donc donc effectivement je suis parti
avait pas de politique culturelle et que
la plus politique culturelle on va y
venir se décide à l'elysée et par alexis
colère donc je pense que c'est compliqué
dakar général de la culture d' emmanuel
macron de toute façon je pense que c'est
un choix plutôt politique exactement
c'est un choix d'un électorat c'est un
choix de la popularité aussi besoin de
quelqu'un de populaire que les marges de
manoeuvre n'existe absolument pas a fait
valoir mme annoncé le secrétaire général
de l'elysée qui est décidemment de la
culture audiovisuelle audiovisuelle il a
la main sur le duel moi c'était quand
même déçu j'ai donc sur l'audiovisuel
par exemple je devais avoir une mission
avec l'accord y avait l'accord du
président il y avait l'accord du premier
ministre avait les gants et
effectivement ça a bloqué sa a été
bloqué par alexis colère qui m'a
expliqué que effectivement il pensait
qu'il fallait d'abord qu'ils disent ce
qu'il fallait faire et ensuite on verra
ça veut dire par exemple c'est
aujourd'hui qu'il m'a dit roselyne
bachelot un secrétaire d'état ou
plusieurs par exemple à l'audiovisuel
pour ça que ça se décidera forcément
c'est pas l'air moi j'ai une théorie sur
secrétaire d'état du visuel d'abord pour
vous dire que par exemple un exemple
très précis quand françoise nyssen fait
son sa conférence de presse sur
l'audiovisuel public le 5 juin 2018
on est avec le premier ministre on est
censé annoncer pas grand chose plutôt
une concertation sur les offres un coup
de téléphone du secrétaire général
alexis colère pendant qu'on est un petit
déjeuner on n'est pas au courant et qui
demande que qui coup de fil à philippe
la mise la culture et qui dit c'est pas
très moderne truc qui confond d'abord
les enfants et les jeunes et qui demande
la bascule de france 4 sur le numéro
tout numérique ça a été décidé comme ça
on est sorti on a appris ça une décision
de dernière minute sans discussion et
france 4 est supprimée de cette manière
là voyez alors voir ce qu'il en est et
va atterrir finalement puisque les
choses ont un peu bougé avec la crise
hannibal oui oui bien sûr on verra je
veux dire c'est l'addition est prise de
cette manière et on doit tous accepté
alors qu'on est censé ouvrir une
concertation sur les offres alors si ça
se passe comme ça à roselyne bachelot
pensait qu'elle a à faire sa place donc
et donc secret je reviens sur le
secrétariat d'état
et après la lettre est anormalement il
va y en avoir un vous avez raison mais
non pas parce que il ya eu comme vous
l'avez vu il y en a jamais eu et la
ministre ou le ministre ministre de la
culture on dit pas audiovisuel
communication parce que je pense
qu'effectivement ces traités ailleurs
par le secrétaire général
pourquoi il va y en avoir un aujourd'hui
pas parce qu'on voulait qui en est un
mais parce que y'a un conte une forme de
conflit d'intérêts parce que la ministre
ne peut pas vraiment s'occuper
d'audiovisuel puisque chronicle a été
chroniqueur sur lci
le sujet est donc effectivement le sujet
d'un secrétariat d'état va se poser pour
ces raisons là mais sinon c'est pas
quelque chose qui était voulu donc pour
pour revenir dans une bâche longs mois
je pense que alors là je j'allais dire
je lui je je la soutiens parce que je
pense qu'effectivement la culture étant
sinistrés on n'a absolument pas besoin
au jeu en tout cas moi aujourd'hui j'ai
pas du tout envie de dire des choses
polémique désagréable par rapport à
quand on regarde les professionnels va
lire des loges c'est tout le monde salue
son arrivée pour le moment est ce que
c'est c'est ce que vous pensez si je
regarde par exemple on peut prendre
olivier py directeur du festival
d'avignon c'est une lionne une battante
une femme de conviction qui connaît la
technocratie dur il va falloir se battre
avec les technocrates de bercy qui ne
sont pas passionnés par l'art vous êtes
sur cette ligne là aussi vivement
qu'elle se mette au travail
il serait difficile de douchez alors on
enthousiasme le mot est peut-être un peu
fort mais la confiance qu en tant
qu'entrepreneur je place en l
aujourd'hui parce que ça serait terrible
de débuter le chantier avec le voilà le
travail qui est en face de nous qui est
absolument colossal et sur lequel elle
ni personne autour d'elle la droit
d'échouer donc après oui c'est juste
pour nous entrepreneurs particulièrement
du spectacle privé dans la musique on a
des relations qui conte souvent était
lointaine avec avec le ministère de la
culture on va toujours les vous avez une
mélomane rue de valois une une
lyricomanes qui adore la musique baroque
la musique lyrique l'opéra
voilà j'espère qu'elle va voir du rap
dans dans dans son environnement non
c'est l'histoire d esthétique c'est
aussi c'est aussi un vrai sujet mais
après ce qu'on peut dire effectivement
c'est que ça fait 20 ans que je produis
des festivals des festivals de rock
j'ai passé une dizaine de ministres de
la culture et donc c'est assez compliqué
de faire du travail de fond quand on
part de si loin
c'est à dire des esthétiques dont je
m'occupe camp quand le turnover est
aussi aussi rapide mais là le en fait on
n'a pas le choix
voilà il faut ça joue pas au siècle je
pense qu'en cénac les régions avec
plutôt forcément par le ministère est ce
qu'on peut pas s'entendre avec une
région est monté un bon festival sans
avoir à compter sur ce qui se passe à
paris c'est ce qu'on fait mais un peu
par la fois un peu par la force des
choses et puis on s'en sort à peu près
bien moi j'ai toujours quand même un peu
un questionnement ça me rend perplexe le
fait que
en 2020 il est encore toujours des
espèces une espèce d'inéquité
complètement profonde et structurelle d
esthétique artistique en france
voilà c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
suffit d'ailleurs ce serait assez
intéressant de voir un peu comment le
l'argent du ministère de la culture et
ses efforts sont répartis en fonction
des esthétiques par exemple pour l'opéra
de paris à une subvention qui est de
l'ordre de 100 millions d'euros pour
l'opéra de paris ça me paraît énorme
c'est parti c'est un fait important et
après on manque un peu d'équité c'est ça
là je vois là moi c'est plutôt la
logique que la juste de quitter calais
qui m'intéresse je voudrais qu'on rentre
dans le dur et notamment dans les
chantiers qui attendent aussi de
bachelot d'abord on va parler du
déconfinement puisque les lieux
culturels ont commencé à rouvrir pas
tous mais des cinémas des théâtres
certains concerts pas tous on va et
venez on est allé voir jean marc
dumontet jean marc dumontet théâtre
point virgule qui a ouvert lui à paris
et c'est clément méric et nathalie guild
war qui l'ont rencontré on attend
beaucoup
toujours d'un nouveau ministre mais je
pense que j'attends de roselyne bachelot
de l'impulsion de l'an viii et ensuite
je sais qu'elle a l'expérience qu'elle a
l'autorité qu'elle a le franc-parler et
qu'elle a une forme de grandes libertés
et je pense que ça va être utile pour
allait peser dans des arbitrages pour
que notre secteur ne soit pas oublié
j'ai envie d'une ministre forte qui
porte ce discours et qui à nos côtés
donne des impulsions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va commencer installe
dans votre peau
bien gentiment
ce qui change d'abord c'est la joie
qu'on éprouve parce que ça fait
longtemps qu on est frustré de pas
pouvoir jouer
donc c'est une renaissance pour nous et
c'est un moment très important
[Musique]
ensuite ce qui compte c'est de bien
accueillir le public le public soit
rassuré en termes sanitaires et donc on
respecte les règles ont été mises en
place pour que les gens viennent
assister un spectacle en étant libérés
et en ayant envie de profiter du
spectacle sans se poser des questions
sanitaires notre vie c'est d'être sur
scène qu'on soit producteur côtoient
artistes
donc c'était une immense frustration
l'ouverture du point virgule s'inscrit
là dedans il faut qu'on réamorcer il
faut qu'on ait un plus
il faut qu'on continue à vivre qu'on
recommence à nier les difficultés ce
qu'il faut redonner le goût au public de
venir donc à nous d'être inventif à nous
d'être créatifs à nous de créer des
urgences les théâtres ils ne seront
jamais arrêté sauf pendant cette
épidémie pour nous avec la livre
stuff barbier renouer avec la vie canton
une deuxième vague menace on sent que
les français sont encore très réticents
à vraiment retrouver les lieux de
culture qui leur sont chers vos théâtre
vous y était retourné depuis vous vous
voyez si le public est au rendez-vous
pas vraiment pas encore retourné comme
spectateur on voit qu'en effet c'est
difficile difficile on pensait qu'ils
auraient peut-être une orgie de
spectacle de la part des gens qui ont
été frustrés pendant plusieurs mois mais
il ya cette peur de de l'épidémie de la
vague de il ya aussi autre chose c'est
tout simplement les spectacles ont été
arrêtées n'ont pas tous repris certains
vont être reprogrammé à la saison
prochaine parce que rien n'a pu être
répétée l'annulation de la plupart des
festivals dont avignon a complètement
perturbé le cycle de production
programmation diffusion tournée donc
vous un peu recalés tout ça ce qu'il
faut espérer c'est que dans le lait
protocole sanitaire qui seront rendus
publics ces prochains jours on autorise
la jauge complète s'il faut commencer à
mettre des rend libre des sièges libres
ça va être une catastrophe
on peut imposer le port du masque aux
spectateurs pour des spectacles courts
c'est supportable on le voit d'ailleurs
quand les gens prennent le train ou
l'avion avec le masque mais il ne faut
pas créer cette distanciation ça tue
l'esprit du public et ça empêche est
vrai que s'il ya des incompréhensions on
laisse le métro évidemment ouvert à tout
le monde mais il est souvent totalement
plein et pas les salles de cinéma avec
ses contraintes sanitaires ni les
concernés ni le théâtre fait ça vous
semble incompréhensible
disons que en tout cas beaucoup de
français ne comprennent pas et de toute
façon ces injonctions contradictoires
sont là depuis depuis plusieurs mois et
il est effectivement on a du mal à
comprendre alors en plus quand
aujourd'hui on nous annonce depuis ce
matin attention seconde vague etc moi je
pense que on ne va pas des confiné
élevé lever les mesures sanitaires avant
longtemps
en tout cas je pense que tout le monde
doit s'attendre à ce que ça dure et on
espère bien sûr le cinéma
j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu mieux
qu'au théâtre comme aller mais moi je
vais premiers retours oui c'est un peu
mieux mais bon on a un problème avec le
cinéma c'est qu'il ya pas de film mais
au delà de et en plus on est dans une
période où le naturellement même sans la
crise c'était pas le mois de juillet qui
était le mois qui était le moi
évidemment de sortie des films mais moi
je voulais quand même dire quelque chose
parce que on a parlé tout à l'heure de
roselyne bachelot en tant que personne
je pense que là il ya une marche contre
est découpée au delà d'elle et de sa
personne qui est en train d'être coupé
par le gouvernement dont évidemment on
parle pas puisqu'on parle aujourd'hui de
déconfinement mais les problèmes dans la
culture et les prennent dans le cinéma
et dans le trech avion c'est pas mal la
vague s'est pas là l'impact et le choc
ça va être effectivement dans les mois
qui viennent et aujourd'hui je dis ça
parce qu'on est en train de discuter de
finir d'imposer de le faire avant 20h et
c'est d'ailleurs les les amendements
concernant la culture qui sont en train
de se faire sabre et là pendant qu'on
est ici parce que on invente de les
défendre on nous demande de les défendre
en vitesse parce qu'il faut finir avant
20 heures
en fait c'est un projet de loi finances
rectificative avec des mesures d'urgence
on est en train de parler mesures
d'urgence quand d'autres pays comme
l'allemagne a déjà proposé son plan de
relance national qui vient d'être
acceptée hier par la commission
européenne
lézina adrien de retard les italiens de
relance mais les italiens on se moque de
temps en temps en septembre ils ont déjà
fait leur plan de relance national est
présentée et nous on est encore dans les
plans dans les plans de mesures
d'urgence
pourquoi je dis ça parce qu'on a à
plusieurs députés trans partisan y
compris des députés en marche j ça parce
que contre l'avis du gouvernement
trans partisan déposer des amendements
de relance notamment dans le cinéma par
exemple et aussi dans le spectacle
vivant il concerne tous ont été rejetés
par le gouvernement ces moments là voilà
on s'attendre à la môme en fait certains
l'automne mais c'est gravissime
parce que on est devant devant la vague
si on ne donne pas aujourd'hui les
moyens
j'allais dire aux employeurs aux
producteurs à ce qui donne de l'emploi
et qui fait qu'ils font là aussi la
meilleure manière
répondre à l'urgence est là que je veux
dire aux problèmes c'est l'activité
s'est pas de prendre des mesures
d'urgence françois missonnier vous donne
la parole tout de suite parce que vous
allez me dire ce que vous attendez et si
vous êtes d'accord avec frédéric dumas
mais il fait tout de suite on va faire
un point sur l'impact de cette crise
économique sur les secteurs de la
culture avec vous rappelle les jambes
nous on croire journaliste économique à
l'opinion et chroniqueur dans cette
émission où on en est au à ce moment en
ce moment là maintenant est-ce qu'on
peut mesurer l'ampleur des dégâts oui
alors il ya une étude qui vient d'être
menée effectivement par ministère de la
culture alors d'abord il faut expliquer
que le secteur de la culture est un
secteur important pour l'économie
française c'est près de 100 milliards
d'euros de production marchande et 47
milliards d'euros de valeur ajoutée
c'est plus de 2% du pis de la création
de richesse nationale en france c'est un
secteur qui est également extrêmement
pourvoyeur d'emplois quatre-vingt mille
entreprises dans le milieu de la culture
et 635 1700 personnes
effectivement et donc la crise
effectivement est venue balayer tout ça
de manière assez violente
cette étude qui a été commandé par
ministère de la culture estime que le
chiffre d'affaires global du secteur de
la culture devrait baisser en moyenne de
près de 25%
un quart du chiffre d'affaires sabrer
mais vous avez des secteurs qui vont
beaucoup plus souffrir que cette moyenne
les plus touchés c'est le spectacle
vivant bien sûr - 72% du chiffre
d'affaires le patrimoine -36% les arts
visuels -31% larchitecture -28%
la crise est extrêmement violente pour
tous ces secteurs
il y en a d'autres qui tirent leur
épingle du jeu les jeux vidéo par
exemple ou les plateformes numériques
numérique plutôt bien c'est que
l'appareil ou pas alors on vais pas tout
de suite puisque on voit
qu'effectivement dans les salles de
spectacles tout le monde n'est pas
revenu encore il ya toujours une crainte
la croissance repart de manière générale
plutôt bien les surprises sont plutôt
bonnes mais on ne rattrapera pas le
niveau de croissance qu'on avait pu
connaître en vend ce sera pas un v ce
sera plutôt une racine carrée on va
rebondir mais moins vite et la pente
sera variable d'ajustement dans le décès
des français 35 mn et quand vous
entendez ce tableau là cet état des
lieux
vous vous dites quoi il ya moyen au fond
d'obtenir encore quelque chose ou on va
souffrir et pour longtemps dans mais
c'est une nécessité d'obtenir encore
quelque chose mais mais mais il va
falloir effectivement son de s'en donner
les moyens falloir instaurer un dialogue
n'existe pas non plus forcément de
manière complètement complètement
optimale aujourd'hui on parlait des
règles sur le déconfinement a
aujourd'hui les règles qui sont imposés
aux salles d'eau salle de concert elles
sont complètement irréaliste voilà c'est
une personne 4 mètres carrés contre dans
les conditions habituelles trois
personnes par mètre carré c'est une
jauge / 12
donc on est à la fois sur le vécu du
spectacle dans des choses qu'on rien à
voir avec ce qu'on a fait et
économiquement c'est absolument pas
c'est absolument pas faisable et et la
sueur sur la sur la relance déjà il va
falloir qu'on parle maintenant
sérieusement de quel protocole sanitaire
on met en place
on respecte tous d'accord lettres avec
les professionnels soient les temps les
fonctionnaires discutant avec les
professionnels dès la rentrée compris
quand on parle de vague 2 comme on dit
du coronavirus ça semble un peu mais
compliqué de réfléchir à cette actualité
vient percuter il faut pas fonctionné
les professionnels c'est à dire que nous
sommes nous sommes des professionnels on
accueille du public
le premier souci que nous avons qu on
organise des festivals des concerts
c'est la sécurité du public
donc on ne fera pas n'importe quoi les
professionnels ne demande pas à ce qu'on
fasse n'importe quoi mais qu'on fasse
les choses les choses peuvent être
assouplies aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya
pas de cohérence dans les différentes
mesures qui sont sur le banc sur le plan
sectoriel absolument vous
personnellement vous avez vous avez un
manque à gagner de combien nous on
l'annulation du festival europavox et
25% du budget qui est 2 millions d'euros
qu'avec étaient déjà engagés donc c'est
un peu plus cinq cent mille euros
qu'avait de pertes engagé irrécupérable
parce que récupérables il ya eu des
aides des aides de l'état regard de ce
qu'ils valent des milliards qui ont été
mis sur la table vous qu'est-ce que vous
avez perçu comme lt du chômage partiel
les aides de l'état et 50 millions
aujourd'hui
voilà d'euros le chômage partiel donc
pour pour une partie d'issue à
aujourd'hui pour pour les projets comme
le mien et il y avait une remarque sur
le soutien des collectivités locales
tout à l'heure c'est le maintien des
subventions
donc là il ya eu un premier mouvement de
la part des collectivités ville région
qui a été plutôt dans la solidarité
il faut pas que ça s'arrête donc il faut
qu'il ya un maintien à l'identique des
subventions ça sera la seule façon pour
les structures comme les miennes ne pas
la perdre la paire tous âges c'est sûr
et certain mais il faut préciser que 5
milliards on passe très rapidement comme
ça 5 milliards c'est une somme colossale
il ya quand même un véritable réforme
budgétaire à compter la prolongation du
statut d'intermittent trop une annexe
hector frédéric dumas oui mais justement
c'est milliards dont on parle c'est
savoir est-ce que ils sont bien utilisés
pour entendre là je dis juste qu'on est
en train de colmater au lieu de relancer
et le vrai problème qu'on va avoir
donc c'est bien de colmater et par
exemple on dit c'est pratiquement un
milliard pour les intermittents qui
finalement que c'est très bien mais ce
qui serait encore mieux c'est qu'ils
puissent travailler
donc en gros c'est de celle activité qui
permet d anne intermittents par essence
en plus hautes
évidemment tout le monde tombe sur les
intermittents disant exemple un argent
parce qu'on leur propose d'être payés à
ne pas travailler mais ce qu'ils veulent
c'est travailler donc c'est relancer
l'activité et c'est ce que je voulais
dire vraiment important c'est que
aujourd'hui un problème de jauge dans
les salles de spectacles dans les salles
de cinéma est haute et dans l'est dans
les concerts donc il ya déjà un problème
d'amortissement des coups mais en gros
ce qu'on oublie c'est que dans quelques
mois il n'y aura plus les d'offres c'est
à dire que même si imaginons que dans
quelques mois
tout redevient qu'on peut revenir dans
les salles messi a plus les films alors
on a eu hier j'avais un dîner justement
coprésident a dîné sur le sujet de
l'audiovisuel il y avait tous les
acteurs du secteur mais même de canal+ à
orange à ocs en parlant des jeunes
d'aller dans un moment donné il n'y aura
pas les films alors netflix à la lettre
songez que ils ont repris tous les
tournois et eux ça va y aller à fond
non mais il y aura avec l'écran il
manque pour comprendre en gros les
blockbusters américains ont décidé de
faire des sorties et coordonnée mondiale
et retiennent pour l'instant leur leur
distribution c'est ça ce qui explique
qu'ils aient pas de nous non non non non
non non je vous parle les tournages aux
locaux une chose il ya du soulagement
parle évidemment de la production
française parce que d'accord je veux
dire l'emploi de la production
américaine c'est tant mieux pour eux
mais et tant mieux pour le secteur bas
par les pénuries d'eau france mais parce
que les films si vous tournez se pouvait
pas tourner les films et si on arrive
ici et si les financeurs ne sont pas
soutenus c'est à dire le producteur
l'employeur celui parce qu'aujourd'hui
on ne lui permet je vous donne un
exemple crédit d'impôt on a déposé tout
à l'heure un crédit d'impôt qui s'est
fait rejeter il ya un crédit d'impôt
cinéma qui est due en fonction des
dépenses qu'on fait en france évidemment
comme n'y a pas eu de tournage
évidemment le crédit d'impôt n'est pas
perçu n'est pas perçu donc ce qui est
parce qu on a proposé on a dit puisque
il n'a pas été perçu à enveloppe
constante puisqu'ils auraient dû être
perçus
est-ce que vous pouvez augmenter le
plafond c'est à dire le montant par film
pour pouvoir relancer pour que le
producteur puis sera incitée à retourner
à investir dans les très mal est ravi
d'avoir fonds de garantie pour le pur
pour le tournage mais il préfère ne pas
l'utiliser lorsque fonds de garantie ça
veut dire qu'il a dû interrompre son
tournage
donc c'est pas c'est parce qu'ils
souhaitent si on interrompt le tournage
ait pas de film donc on leur dit de
redonner un peu d'argent aux producteurs
pour qu'ils puissent produire pour que
dans un an quand son film sortira parce
que s'il ya plus de films à sortir et
ben on aura les blockbusters américains
qui eux vont d'ailleurs à priori
beaucoup d'américains vont venir tourner
pour les prochains du temps en europe 10
dans les pays
safe puisqu'il ya eu moins de crises
sanitaires en roumanie et autres donc
vous moi je vous parle de la production
future
les blockbusters américains qui sont
tournées ils vont tous arrivés en
automne
ce que vous devez lire en gros un
encombrement dans les 50 places pour le
film français on prend pas les bonnes
décisions il va y avoir aujourd'hui au
coût de morts sur la route sont les
vrais que nature est-ce qu'on peut
essayer de comprendre de quoi l'avenir
sera fait il ya des scénarios qui se
dessine une bulle d'inactivité il ya une
bulle aussi de rupture de créativité
si le marché repart il repartira avec
les plus puissants en position de force
est en effet pour le cinéma les
blockbusters américains
plusieurs très grosses affiches se sont
déplacés à l'automne donc ça risque
d'achever d'étouffer les petites
créations en termes de puissance
économique que sont les créations
françaises alors qu'elles sont très
puissantes en inventivité en créativité
artistique donc c'est ça l'enjeu et ça
c'est une des tâches pour roselyne
bachelot c'est faire en sorte qu on
écarte peut-être les lames les mâchoires
de cet étau pour que non seulement
financièrement économiquement mais
artistiquement esthétiquement il avait
brillé de nouveau une place à sa manière
les deux sens on lire en complément des
chiffres que vous citiez tout à l'heure
sur le spectacle vivant privé c'est 2
milliards 4 donc de perte et 51% des
entreprises qui sont menacés de faillite
très directement parce qu'on est sur un
souvent sur un tissu qui n'est pas
subventionné qui dépend de la
billetterie qui s'est arrêté qui n'est
pas encore reparti et avec des tpe pme
qui maillent le territoire qui font
vivre aussi beaucoup de gens mais qui
sont extrêmement fragiles puisque le
taux de marge est proche de zéro voire
légèrement les déjà dire que les
artistes vont devoir être moins payés
ils vont devoir et au revoir un peu à la
baisse leurs prétentions j'ai dérangé
plus des plus des plus célèbres c'est
déjà le cas dans le théâtre et pas que
pour les plus célèbres c'est sûr que
toutes les économies se réduisent on
réduit le nombre d'acteurs sur le sur
scène donc ont choisi des pièces à petit
distribution il ya une pression sur les
carrières il ya moyen de relancer cette
machine l'ensemble de l'économie qui
s'est contracté c'est à dire la culture
ce que vous dites là sur la culture est
vrai sur l'ensemble des secteurs de
l'économie
il faut s'attendre à la rentrée à des
vagues de licenciements très importante
on estime que 10 mille entreprises
supplémentaires devrait faire défaut à
la rentrée donc c'est quelque chose
qu'on a sur l'ensemble de l'économie et
la culture qui par essence est un
secteur déjà beaucoup beaucoup aidé et
dont la rentabilité n'est effectivement
pas toujours très forte sera forcément
forcément impactées par cette crise
le la clé la clé de la relance ce sera
très certainement de détendre ses
contraintes de barrières sanitaires qui
empêche aujourd'hui les consommateurs
les téléspectateurs avec des marques et
les barrières sanitaires évidemment
elles sont centrales mais et le tout
numérique au fond
numériser totalement le monde de la
culture est ce qu'ils sont pas allés les
gisements en feu emploi je pose la
question
non mais en fait moi c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles d'ailleurs j'ai
quitté le groupe en marche et que je me
suis opposé à ce gouvernement qui est
passée qui était le tout numérique
je veux dire il faut absolument que
honda on garde les deux piliers c'est à
dire que moi j'appelle alors va à chaque
fois je prends comme exemple par exemple
canal+ et leclerc il faut du linéaire
qui est un peu la vitrine et la
promotion etc
et après on va effectivement dans le
magasin may en plus les fractures
comment on peut aujourd'hui proposer du
tout numérique alors qu'on sait qu'il ya
des fractures territoriales cadets
fracture numérique évidemment mais qui a
des fractures d'usagé donc c'est vous
dire il faut absolument marché sur les
deux piliers et je voulais juste redire
parce qu'elle ne méritait pas une
réponse à la fracture territoriale juste
pas non ces territoires isolés du
spectacle vous savez la parole à la
tribune sur les chèques du pass culture
c'est exactement ça enfin parce
numérique comment voulez vous qu'ils
fonctionnent il peut pas fonctionner
puisque les dans les territoires dans
lequel il est censé apporter quelque
chose puisque si le pass culture dont
les publics c'est pas la peine
et bien c'est des territoires où il n'ya
pas de deux de ses numéros ya des zones
blanches et en plus y'a pas d'offre donc
le numérique dans un endroit il ya une
zone blanche où il n'ya pas de débit
c'est là ça aggrave la fracture ni la
fracture culturelle et je voudrais qu'on
termine sur un symbole le 1% vous savez
culture du budget on n'est même pas
encore aujourd'hui alors ça suffira
peut-être pas à résorber cette crise
dans les secteurs de la culture mais
mais vous demandez-vous france a mitonné
que ce budget culture vraiment augmente
on sait que le budget justice va
augmenter et que et que les on est en
pleine phase de discussions budgétaires
à la rentrée ce serait déjà un gros
geste
ça serait un geste absolument
indispensable
à l'époque actuelle est à nouveau avec
une vraie réflexion ce que ce que ce
qu'on demande sur la manière de derrière
dans les glaces dans les sommes sont
répartis et donc de les quitter le
secteur public secteur privé divers et
transparent sur le fléchage et les
esthétiques 1%
c'était c'est une promesse on n'y est
pas encore aujourd'hui 1% du budget
d'état pour la culture faut s'arracher à
ce symbole parce qu'on peut l'atteindre
très facilement en faisant rentrer
dedans des budgets périphériques donc
c'est artificiel
ailleurs c'est pas une dépense la
culture c'est un investissement on l'a
vu ça dégage de la valeur est en effet
il faut remettre à plat la distribution
de cet argent c'est à dire politique de
subvention c'est ça souvent qui est
faussé par un saupoudrage ou par des
iniquités merci beaucoup merci
infiniment d'être venus débattre de la
culture que nous aimons beaucoup ici à
lcp on va s'intéresser à présent un
autre sujet dont on parle peu trop peu
d'ailleurs l'impact de la crise
sanitaire sur la santé mentale
cela fait plusieurs semaines que les
psychiatres alerte sur les conséquences
du confinement la consommation de
psychotropes a explosé alors avant d'en
parler avec nos invités on va regarder
ce témoignage
rabhi cas et maïté frémont ont rencontré
une aide-soignante dans une ehpad qui a
fini par craquer deux mois que la crise
est passé deux mois que charlotte 56 ans
peine à se relever
le coup vite dit elle est venue briser
20 ans de carrière del médico
psychologique
elle travaille en ehpad et n'avait
jamais rien vécu de tel en l'espace de
quelques semaines elle a accompagnés
jusqu'à leur décès mon trentaine de
résidents malades du code vide
vous savez quand vous êtes enfin dit
souvent les familles en droit de venir
vous accompagne y sont à vos côtés
il vous tiennent la main il vous rassure
j'essaie de vous accompagner au mieux et
là c'était le faisait un peu notre rôle
de soignant évidemment mais on ne
pouvait pas faire venir les familles
donc c'était très difficile lorsque les
résidents disait je veux voir ma fille
il était seul en pleine crise l alerte
sa direction du manque de moyens sans
réponse elle contacte la rs une démarche
qui selon elle il lui a valu une mise à
l'éloignement
c'est totalement anormal compte qu
puisqu'elle nous pousser à l'éloignement
parce qu'on a lancé une alerte pour
faire un appel au secours tout
simplement pour nous donner du matériel
pour nous donner des pour nous donner
plus de courage pour continuer à
combattre le commis depuis charlotte
lutte contre la dépression
elle est suivie par un psychologue je
prends des médicaments la journée pour
oublier que j'existe ou que pour essayer
d'oublier ce qu'on a fait endurer et je
dors plus de la nuit je suis au bord de
faire une bêtise je suis très mal
tout ce que j'ai soigné sont tous morts
donc tous les jours les familles
m'appelle même encore les familles
m'appelle d'origine mais j'essaye de les
aider au mieux mais bon je suis déjà pas
bien moi même comment voulez vous que je
récompense les autres et après on dit
que je suis médico psychologique mais là
franchement c'est difficile d'avoir
cette appellation là ont tout ce que
j'ai vu le c'est un traumatisme
tellement puissant plus une direction
qui s'est complètement détachée tout ça
qui n'a même pas pris conscience du mal
qu'ils enduraient je suis écoeuré de mon
travail et je suis surtout très perturbé
très inquiète de mon avenir je me
demande ce que j'ai de venir ici si je
vais me relever
voilà c'est un sujet qui a été réalisé
grâce à l'aide de l'association sps
soins aux professionnels de santé qui
disposent d'un numéro vert que je vous
donne immédiatement le 0 805 23 23 36
c'est un appel gratuit et c'est un appel
24 heures sur 24 possibles de bonsoir à
l'ena zambon soir merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes là contrôleur général des
lieux privatifs de liberté de privation
de liberté en général on pense à la
prison il n'y a pas que la prison
il ya aussi les hôpitaux psychiatriques
vous allez nous en parler puisque vous
faites des visites inopinées des visites
surprises dans ces lieux là et vous
allez nous expliquer ce que vous avez
découvert bienvenue à vous marion
leboyer ravis de vous accueillir à
nouveau sur ce plateau vous êtes
psychiatre directrice des départements
universitaire de psychiatrie de
l'hôpital henri mondor à créteil en 2018
vous tiriez déjà la sonnette d'alarmé
sur la psychiatrie à l'hôpital
psychiatrique état d'urgence c'était
chez fayard et par skype en duplex nous
attend martin vos nerfs bonsoir vous
êtes député écologie démocratie
solidarité du bas rhin fait une région
qui a évidemment été terriblement
touchés par le cos vide et vous êtes
psychiatre d'ailleurs toujours en
exercice je vais d'abord commencé avec
vous marion leboyer mais ce qu'on
aimerait comprendre
au fond ce à quoi vous faites face vous
parlez d'une nouvelle vague une vague de
nouveaux patients qui déferle dans les
services psychiatriques
de quoi souffre-t-il est ce que ce sont
deux des patients qui ne fréquentaient
pas les hôpitaux psychiatriques par le
passé ou des services psychiatriques
de quoi souffre-t-il de quel trouble
souffrent tout particulièrement dans
cette période là c'est une très bonne
question parce que c'est clair que la
préco vide si on y est en ce moment il
sera psychiatrique et que c'est devant
nous donc pendant la pandémie on sait
que nos patients certains d'entre eux
ont été en rupture de soins et donc
rechute est donc arrivée à l'hôpital
mais ce qui est le aussi extrêmement
clair c'est qu'il ya toute une
population de la population qui n'a
jamais été malade et qui arrivent à
l'hôpital pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que la population
générale a été exposé à toute une série
de facteurs stressants d'isolement
social d'augmentation d'addiction de
toute une série de difficultés en
particulier
les soignants vous en parlais à
l'instant qui ont vécu des choses
extrêmement difficile pas que dans les
ehpad dans les ehpad mais aussi par des
soignants mais aussi des femmes qui se
sont exprimés en disant qu'elles étaient
13 en souffrance et puis des populations
précaires qui sont particulièrement
vulnérables et qui sont particulièrement
souffert de l'enfermement ou de
l'éloignement du l enfermement de
proches ou du déconfinement c'est à dire
du moment où vous dit vous pouvez
ressortir
ils ont souffert de toute une série de
facteurs qui sont l'isolément social qui
sont le stress lié à l'inconnu le deuil
dans certains cas le fait que leurs
proches ont été hospitalisés quelquefois
des violences dont on a aussi entendu
parler donc ils ont développé un certain
nombre de pathologies
lesquels qu'est-ce qui viennent voiler
le meur et surtout des troubles anxieux
donc on sait qu'il ya une augmentation
dans les pays voisins qui ont commencé à
faire des études statistiques à peu près
30% de nouveaux cas et nous on a la
fondation fondamental créer une
plateforme qui s'applique au vide écoute
qui a fonctionné entre la mi-avril et la
mi-mai et on a constaté que parmi les
patients ou les personnes qui appelait
qui avait vraiment des pathologies
dépressives et anxieuse y avait près de
70% de nouveaux consultants certaines
personnes qui n'avaient jamais été
malade
auparavant donc ça c'est une première
population laquelle il faut qu'on veille
et qu'on soit particulièrement vigilants
et devant nous se profile aussi
probablement des conséquences liées aux
conséquences économiques qui vont
arriver probablement le chômage les
difficultés financières qui vont aussi
faire le lit de la dépression est un
autre phénomène auquel il faut être très
vigilant
c'est des personnes qui ont été
infectées par le caue vide qui ont des
séquelles inflammatoire de l'infection
et ses séquelles inflammatoires on sait
qu'elles font le lit de la dépression
c'est une caractérisation biologique a
peur tellement connu ça ne partait mais
non la maladie
non non c g c'est vraiment la partie
biologique c'est une maladie comme les
autres la dépression et donc on sait
aujourd'hui très bien qu'il ya des
conséquences immunologique t'es pas là
des psychiatres x et touchant les minots
psychiatrie et donc ça a déjà été décrit
dans les précédentes pandémies
le sarc par exemple où on a une
augmentation de 30% là aussi de troubles
de l'humeur sévère marquée par la
persistance de séquelles inflammatoires
donc pour toutes ces raisons là il faut
être extrêmement vigilant et savoir
reconnaître chez un patient qui a eu le
coc vide qui reste fatigué il faut être
capable de dépister s'ils ont d'autres
signes que la fatigue merci
dante qui doivent faire dépister
diagnostiquer et traiter un épisode
dépressif et face à ces nouveaux malades
que vous avez vu arriver dans vos
services
est-ce que l'hôpital était prêt est ce
que le bêta la tenue c4 est grand temps
alors l'hôpital je sais pas je voulais
service si on l'a déjà dit à plusieurs
reprises l'hôpital psychiatrique sur ma
maison qui leur dira tout à l'heure qui
est en crise depuis longtemps qui est en
difficulté et bien sûr quant à une crise
comme ça la difficulté les difficultés
augmentent encore plus ce qu'on peut
dire de façon très claire c'est que
pendant la pandémie on a tenu on a
rappelé toutes les files actives de
patients les cmp ont travaillé
énormément on a développé des
innovations ça a été aussi quelque chose
de positif finalement cette crise parce
que par exemple on réclame depuis des
années d'avoir des téléconsultations en
quelques jours ça a été là et on a pu
appeler nos patients et les garder en
consultation leur envoyer des consulter
des ordonnances donc la maintien de la
prise en charge de nos fils active ont
été là il ya eu d'autres innovations
comme ces plateformes dont je parlais à
l'instant qui ont permis d'améliorer
l'accès de faciliter l'accès l'accès aux
soins
donc il ya toute une série de
dispositifs qui ont été très performants
et qui ont tenu et puis il ya d'autres
dispositifs innovants par exemple on a
comme toutes les autres disciplines
médicales ou vers des unités spécifiques
pour les patients atteints de maladies
psychiatriques et de qu'ovide est une
des spécificités que moi j'ai constaté
avec beaucoup de plaisir c'est que le
cloisonnement dont on se plaint beaucoup
entre médecins généralistes entre
psychiatre entre pharmaciens a sauté à
travailler ensemble on a pris en charge
ensemble ces patientes ce qui est
insuffisamment fait dans nos services
habituellement alors je voulais faire un
état des lieux parce que vous êtes
vraiment voilà au coeur au coeur de ce
qui se passe à l'hôpital
je vais je vais aller voir martin
bonheur parce que c'est un peu son
cheval de bataille depuis depuis déjà
plusieurs mois depuis d'ailleurs son
élection à l'assemblée
de quoi pouvez-vous témoigner parce que
vous avez choisi de continuer à
travailler
qu'avez vous vu qu avez-vous compris de
ses conséquences psychiatrique du coc
vide dans votre région
alors c'est vrai que la région grand est
a été une des régions les plus les plus
impactés
et il y a eu comme marion le disais à
l'instant dans la région nantaise
l'organisation d'une écoute tout à fait
spécifique de deux plateformes une
écoute codip 6,67 organisé d'ailleurs
par le confrère dominique martelli qui
coordonne habituellement la cellule
d'urgence médico psychologique donc une
écoute en fait tenu par que des
psychiatres à laquelle j'ai participé
qui était au départ uniquement une
écoute pour les soignants et votre votre
interview introductif le reportage que
nous avons pu voir et cette aide
soignante
très clairement les soignants ont été
particulièrement mis à mal dans les
trois régions île de france offrant ses
grands ajustements jusqu'à qu'est ce que
vous disent les soignants parce que on
se dit bêtement que si c'est trop
insupportable se passe à cette vague
d'épidémie
le droit de retrait existe ça passait
sais pas ce qui s'est passé dans les
hôpitaux
non c'est pas c'est pas du tout ce qui
s'est passé c'est à dire que les
soignants n'ont pas hésité une seule
seconde on disait t'es j'ai failli dire
au front je n'aime pas cette sémantique
de la guerre il faisait il faisait leur
travail avec énormément de d'implication
et ils n'ont jamais hésité à parce qu'il
y avait une situation particulière de
grande fragilité
mais la plupart des soignants et ait été
aux côtés des patients qu'aux vide
sauf que je vous le rappelle la
situation était catastrophique en
matière de protection des soignants les
soigne en était au début absolument pas
protégés ils n'avaient pas de masse
qu'il n'avait pas sur blues on a on a eu
de la chance je vais pas du tout faire
de la publicité pour le crédit mutuel
mais vous savez c'est ces rouleaux en
plastique qu'on met habituellement sur
les tables quand on fait des kermesses
c'est avec ces rouleaux là que les
soignants ont été protégés donc en fait
une situation extrêmement à risque rien
qu'au chu de strasbourg
plus de 650 soignants ont été
contaminées
et avec j'allais dire la carence et
l'insuffisance parce qu'on a une
situation où l'hôpital est très carencée
à la fois l'hôpital j'allais dire
médecine chirurgie obstétrique mais
l'hôpital psychiatrique et j'aimerais en
dire un mot parce que c'était vraiment
pas oublier les oubliés de toutes les
protections donc dépasse d'aidés
soignants qui ont été extrêmement à
risque et toute cette écoute qui s'est
mise en place on a pu entendre des
choses et j'aimerais dire à quel point
marion leboyer a particulièrement raison
quand elle dit que la crise sur le plan
psychique psychiatrique est devant nous
ah oui parce que nous entrons simplement
dans une phase que je vais qualifier de
psycho traumatisme à la fois pour les
citoyens et les citoyennes peut-être
aussi insisté sur le fait que la
communication et les messages qu'ils
étaient envoyés en permanence aux
françaises et aux français étaient des
messages de terreur la direction
générale de la santé et monsieur salomon
je le dis très clairement
en faisant de la communication tous les
tous les soirs à 19h en donnant la
comptabilisation des personnes qui
avaient perdu la vie a complètement
terrorisé les français et dans un style
gros les pointus musique par les mots
posés sur cette crise je pense aux mots
de guerre évidemment d'un mot ont
contribué à créer à créer des mots des
maux psychiques
si les personnels habilités il ya eu une
responsabilité de l'état à la fois dans
l'insuffisance de la protection des
citoyens et des soignants en premier et
une responsabilité en matière de
communication moi je regarde facilement
outre-rhin
puisque je suis une élue de l'alsace et
j'ai pu voir tu constater comment en
allemagne
cela s'est passé et les messages
adressés à la population étaient des
messages de civisme
les messages de remerciements et pas du
tout le radiant que
que les nôtres peut-être on a compris le
message merci beaucoup martin venait on
va parler avec vous maintenant à des
maisons parce que c'est compliqué il ya
des patients qui n'avaient jamais
consulté des services psychiatriques qui
n'était pas forcément fragiles via ce
qu'ils avaient des antécédents fragilité
et puis il y avait ce qui était
hospitalisée au moment du coc vide et
qui se sont retrouvés confinés dans un
espace qui est déjà clos qui c'est
l'enfermement dans l'enfermement
qu'avez vous découvert sur le traitement
de ces patients dans ces hôpitaux
psychiatriques particulier alors je
précise que le contrôle général des
lieux de privation de liberté il est
compétent pour vérifier que les droits
fondamentaux des personnes dans les
hôpitaux psychiatriques comme dans
d'autres lieux sont respectés au moment
où le confinement a été ordonnée nous
avons décidé de continuer nos contrôles
de façon téléphoniques mais je
m'interdisais pas et d'ailleurs j'ai été
amené à le faire mais d'envisager de se
déplacer malgré la crise si on avait le
sentiment qu'il se passait des choses
particulièrement grave
alors ce que nous avons constaté au tout
début et ça rejoint tout à fait ce que
vient de dire martin l'honneur c'est que
justement une fois de plus l'hôpital
psychiatrique en crise comme l'hôpital
général
évidemment l hôpital psychiatrique a été
le dernier servi en fait le parent
pauvre de la médecine et du service
public
pourquoi parce que justement la prendra
au moins une semaine ou dix jours
les psychiatres avec lesquels je
m'entretenais mes équipes s'entretenait
nous disait que 1 il n'avait pas de
recommandation du niveau national alors
que ses recommandations arrivait pour
les hôpitaux genot 2 qu'il n'avait
absolument pas ni de gêne ni de masques
et que quand ces masques arrivait dans
les groupements disons hospitalier pour
pas faire trop technique
ils étaient servis en dernier après les
médecins les médecins somatiques donc
déjà ça c'est quelque chose qui est qui
est très choquant malgré tout les
psychiatres les soignants se sont
vraiment retrousser les manches et on
fait un travail remarquable a partout
parce qu'à lire votre rapport absolument
à faire des choses sur le traitement des
patients et en ce sens et koné
il y a eu un travail remarquable il y a
eu bien sûr des dérives et ses dérives
nous les avons constaté je suis allé
moi-même à l'hôpital de moisselles dans
le val d'oise avec trois cols à
contrôleur collaborateurs et nous avons
découvert une situation absolument
invraisemblable c'est à dire que là où
ça c'était normal une unité qu'ovide
avait été ouverte comme dans tous les
hôpitaux psychiatriques et bien dans
cette unité qu'ovide à moisselles il
avait été décidé d'en fermer à double
tour
les patients atteints du coc vide ce qui
était soupçonné de l'avoir est également
tout ce qui était en train qui arrivait
et dont on ne savait pas s'il l'avait
s'il ne l'avait pas
par précaution on les mettait dans cette
unité au vide mais on les enfermait et
enfin effets personnels parfois effet
personnage ahmad papier sans rien qui
leur appartenaient avec une
dépersonnalisation terrible et puis
surtout aucune possibilité de sortir de
sa chambre puisqu'elle était fermée à
clé au point que et c'est aussi pour ça
que nous y sommes allés au point que une
patiente s'était défenestrée deux jours
avant du deuxième étage heureusement
elle n'est pas décédé mais l'a été quand
même gravement blessé et tout ça c'était
parce que et c'est ce que j'ai dénoncé
j'ai alerté la ministre le ministre
pardon de la santé immédiatement c'est
parce qu'il y avait une confusion opéré
par un certain nombre de médecins et la
direction de l'établissement entre
isolement thérapeutique et confinement
c'est à dire qu'on considérait on ne
s'en ai beaucoup entretenu avec les
médecins et la direction de
l'établissement
il considérait que puisqu'il s'agissait
de malades mentaux il ne pouvait pas ses
ballades intégré la nécessité des gestes
barrières donc par là les isoler
totalise isoler totalement et nous nous
comme d'habitude nous avons vu ces
patients qui nous ont dit pour certains
d'entre eux mais je veux bien tout à
fait gaffe à respecter les gestes
barrière c'est un peu d'argent 4
supporte bien sûr de congrès supporte
pas c'est tout le sens de votre de votre
mission vous même ces cas sont peut-être
exceptionnel que deux
mais on a pris quelques relais c'est à
dire qu'on avait eue c'est là aussi là
je trouve la grandeur du rôle du canton
de genève
on avait eu quelques situations où des
médecins nous ont appelés pour nous dire
qu'est ce qu'on fait si un patient
refuse de respecter les gestes barrière
est ce qu'on peut le mettre à
l'isolément thérapeutique on m'a dit
mais non à l'isolément therapeutics et
uniquement si son état mental justifie
un isolement ça n'est pas du confinement
forcé merci beaucoup je joue pas on va
rester sur le diagnostic la vague est
devant nous on sait qu' il faudrait tout
remettre à plat pour résoudre la crise
de l'hôpital et des services
psychiatriques à l'hôpital ça fera
l'objet d'un autre débat mais je tenais
ce qu'on fasse ce diagnostic on va aller
sourire un peu pour terminer ce débat
avec vous camille à ma journée à
l'assemblée mais je n'oublie pas thomas
des prêts j'arrive camille ma journée à
l'assemblée
c'est thomas des prêts qui va nous
raconter quand en une nuit les députés
ont voté un amendement qui va avoir
quelques conséquences sur notre
consommation de cigarettes n'est ce pas
thomas où exactement myriam les députés
examinent en ce moment dans l'hémicycle
le projet de loi de finances
rectificative pour l'année 2020 et ils
ont adopté hier une disposition qui ne
va pas ravir certains fumeurs jura
compte
[Musique]
ça s'est passé hier soir dans
l'hémicycle les députés ont adopté un
amendement du gouvernement qui vise à
limiter l'achat de tabac à l'étranger
aujourd'hui par exemple si vous allez en
allemagne en italie en espagne vous
pouvez rapporter en france quatre
cartouches de cigarettes
demain ce chiffre est ramené à une seule
cartouche
une mesure de santé publique salué par
de nombreux députés
nous avons fait le choix du paquet de
cigarettes à 10 euros c'est pour inciter
les français à baisser leur consommation
et non pas pour aller chercher des
cigarettes moins chères à l'extérieur de
nos frontières se dire qu'on va arrêter
de ramener à nos tentes à nos ongles à
nos amis quatre cartouches de cigarettes
qui les tuent chacune à petit feu c'est
faire encore un pas important vers la
fin je dirais de du tabagisme
cette mesure elle a aussi un aspect
économique c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
le président de la commission des
finances un élu les républicains l'a
soutenu bonjour eric woerth alors vous
vous avez lancé une mission sur l'impact
du confinement sur notre consommation de
tabac
quelle a été la conséquence de cette
période sur les buralistes français les
buralistes étant restés ouverts marcher
lens était compliqué de se promener et
puis on pouvait pas passer les
frontières donc ils ont réalisé plus de
chiffre d'affaires ils ont vendu plus de
tabac et l'état d'ailleurs encaissé plus
de fiscalité
donc c'était une bonne chose donc
l'amendement porté par le gouvernement
c'est une bonne chose
oui c'est une bonne chose as une bonne
très bonne chose maintenant après faut
les moyens de le vérifier
c'est évidemment toujours extrêmement
compliqué il ya pas l douaniers derrière
chaque voiture
enfin les contrôles sont assez efficaces
ils font beaucoup de travail mais
c'était bien de réduire à diviser par
quatre le volume qu'on peut acheter à
titre personnel à l'étranger
alors pour l'heure l'histoire ne nous
dit pas si cela va faire augmenter le
trafic de cigarettes mais ça on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler dans ma journée
à l'assemblée
mais bien sûr thomas je ne pense qu'à
vous camille est allé un peu vite c'est
votre chronique maintenant avec qui
alors avez vous pris l'apéro j'ai pris
l'apéro avec pierre-yves bournazel
alors il est député agir de paris c'est
un proche de rachida dati et nous avons
bu l'apéro aucun fénéon dans le 18ème
dont il est aussi un élu tu as fait
alors pierre-yves bournazel
il a il a un maire comme ça près mais il
est originaire du cantal il a l'air très
urbain je voulais dire un très citadin
mais il est originaire du cantal terre
de fromage évidemment le cantal le bleu
d'auvergne saint nectaire
mais bizarrement il s'y connaît pas trop
en fromage c'est assez bizarre est
teinté je vais quand même demander
comment il aimait manger son cantal ont
choisi c'est comment vieux pas de nom
pas trop vieux patron mieux vous n'avez
pas quand ces sacs
non parce qu'il est trop fort pour moi
en revanche j'aime bien jamais le chef
moi je voudrais bien que jamais c'est
moins la région ça c'est pas du tout
vers labège plus rien j'aime bien cher
voilà d'accord la brebis
voilà un vrai alors vous allez me dire
pourquoi j'ai demandé à ses goûts en
matière de fromage à pyrène bournazel
salut ben ali mais parce qu'il ya
peut-être un lien entre le fromage et la
politique
ah oui et oui parce que lui il est né
dans le département de georges pompidou
dans la région auvergne de giscard il a
vécu sur les terres de jacques chirac et
de françois hollande
finalement la corrèze ben c'est un peu
comme un grand plateau de fromage c'est
toutes les sensibilités politiques à la
fois
mais ce sont essentiellement quand même
les femmes et des hommes engagés sont
les hommes et les femmes modéré ouais on
aime la modération la pondération et je
pense que c'est une qualité dans le
monde qui vient c'est pareil avec le
cantal finalement pas ce que vous me
dites que vous aimez pas le cantal trop
vieux c'est trop fort en goût immodéré
de la modération
alors oui ce décor est l'empiré
bournazel il a souvent la nostalgie de
son pays liés à des souvenirs d'enfance
bien sûr mais là vous allez voir c'est
pas du tout une histoire de fromage dans
le souvenir d'enfance c'est pas le
fromage
ah bon les souvenirs en france ça serait
plus tôt
l'herbe des prés les ruisseaux les
papillons l'air de la montagne puisque
dans le cantal vous avez la montagne
d'inscrits avec mon grand-père au col de
lacq et chaque année lorsque je reviens
dans le cantal je vais au col de lacq
manger une crêpe la confiture de
myrtilles voilà je vais au puy mary
oui c'est plutôt ça mais mes souvenirs
d'enfance il a plein de petites
madeleines loyer alors bien qu'ils ne
soient pas en marche pierre-yves
bournazel c'est un marcheur il fait au
moins dix mille pas par jour
ils adorent ça parfois il de même ces
rendez-vous en marchant c'est son secret
pour être en forme mais quand on est
député
le problème c'est qu'il faut aussi
rester chic et surtout rester fidèle à
ses convictions alors quelles chaussures
at il choisi dans la chaussure vraiment
pour le coup mais s'est lâché sur votre
droit a lancé en fin de droit où on peut
marcher et puis on peut aller à
l'assemblée
je préfère me montrez nous on voit bien
la semaine c'est caoutchouc et le dessus
et centre droit vous savez je pense
qu'il ya des gens de gauche comme à
droite pour des plus belles chaussures
que moi on est d'accord que l'a71 deux
ans mon cas c'est avec du caoutchouc
donc pour marcher c'est comme si on
était dans une basket
donc on peut marcher on peut faire ses
activités puis quand on va à l'assemblée
nationale vous regarde pas en disant
tiens lui signant basket mais dans les
chaussures de ville souple tout non pas
un côté politiquement marqués comme ça à
mon nom on ne le voit pas le 2 juin
on voit que deux cibles avec vous
camille les députés sont vraiment
différents qu'avec moi je m'étonne je ne
comprends pas merci beaucoup pour ce
nouveau portrait à la face aux
affairistes merci mesdames marie me
boyer à des maisons merci infiniment
martin bonheur merci à vous également
c'est la sainte cette émission on se
retrouve mardi prochain
[Musique]